musk as you said
is driven by Mission more than any
person I've ever seen
and it's not only mission is like Cosmic
missions
meaning he's got three really big
missions one
is to make humans a space-faring
civilization make us multi-planetary or
get us to Mars
number two is to bring us into the era
of sustainable energy to bring us into
the era of electric vehicles and solar
roofs and um battery packs and third is
to make sure that artificial
intelligence is safe and is aligned with
human values and every now and then I'd
talk to them and we'd be talking about
starlinks satellites or whatever
or he would be pushing the people in
front of him in SpaceX and saying if you
do this we'll never get to Mars in our
lifetime and then he would give the
lecturer how important it was for human
consciousness to get to Mars in our
lifetime and I'm thinking okay this is
the pep talk of somebody trying to
inspire a team or maybe it's the type of
of uh pontification you do on a podcast
but on like the 20th time I watched him
I realized okay I believe it he actually
is driven by this he is frustrated and
angry that because of this particular
minor engineering decision
the big mission is not going to be
accomplished it's not a pep talk it's a
literal frustration
and impatience of frustration
and
um
it's also
just probably the most deeply ingrained
thing in him is his mission he joked at
one point to me about how much he loved
reading comics as a kid and he said all
the people in the comic books they're
trying to save the world but they're
wearing their underpants on the outside
and they look ridiculous and then he
paused and said but they are trying to
save the world and whether it's starlink
in Ukraine or Starship going to Mars or
trying to get a global new Tesla I think
he's got this epic sense of the role
he's going to play in helping Humanity
on big things
and like the the characters in the comic
books it's sometimes ridiculous but it
also is sometimes true